welcome to today's video where we dive
deep into the interesting world of
hacking we'll explore how hacking
actually works debugging mids and
shedding light on the processes involved
by the end of this video you will have a
clear understanding of this complex
object so let's get started and before
we begin if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional where
they sets to switch careers with cyber
security while learning from the experts
then dragging a show to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of Engineering the course link
is mentioned in the description box and
pin comment that will navigate you to
the course page where you can find a
complete audio of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press on
the Bell icon to nourish on future
content so stay tuned with us until the
end of this video and don't forget to
register your opinion in the comment
section below so now first let's define
hacking hacking is the unauthorized
access manipulation or exploitation of
computer systems or networks it's
crucial to note that not only hacking is
malicious some ethical hackers work to
improve security and there are different
types of hackers including black hat
hackers the bad guys white hat hackers
the good guys and gray hat hackers
somewhere in between each has different
motivations and intentions now let's
delve into the methods hackers use
hackers have an arsenal of tools such as
key loggers Reds that is remote access
torsions and DDOS that is DDOS attacks
distributed denial of service and we
will discuss these tools and their
functions and how hackers use them to
hack and I hope you guys have heard
about the major hacking incidents like
the Equifax bridge and the stuxnet bomb
so these were the major hacking events
that happened during cyber security era
and now we'll see how hackers hack with
an example keep in mind that this
explanation is for educational purposes
and should not be used for illegal
activities and and I have an
announcement for you guys that is if you
want to Kickstart your career as a cyber
security professional in six months then
try giving a show to Simple learn
skeltics cyber security bootcamp the
course link or the bootcampling is
mentioned in the description box and pin
comment that will navigate you to do The
Bootcamp page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and starting with the first
method that is password cracking so we
will discuss the steps how hackers use
this method to hack a person system or
the targeted systems so the first is
Target identification so the hacker
identifies a Target account or system
they want to access and then the step
two they do is password enumeration they
gather information about the target such
as username email address for any
publicly available information then
there comes the step 3 password guessing
using various techniques the hacker
attempts to guess the password either
manually or with automated Tools in then
comes the step 4 success or failure if
the hacker successfully guesses the
password they gain unauthorized access
if not they may try different
combinations or other methods so this
was about the method password cracking
and these were the steps which hackers
use to hack the persons or the targeted
systems now moving on to the second
method that is malware infections so
here we will see the steps so the first
step in this method is malware Creation
The Hacker creates or requires malicious
software such as viruses Trojans or
spyware stack in Step that is the
delivery the hacker needs to deliver the
malware to the victim they may use email
attachments infected websites or social
engineering techniques to entice the
victim to download or execute the menu
step 3 installation once the victim
executes the malware it installs itself
on the device often without their
knowledge then comes the step 4
malicious actions the malware carries
out its intended Malaysia sections such
just stealing data monitoring activities
or providing remote access to the hacker
so this is how hackers use this
technique that is the malware infection
technique to hack the targeted systems
now moving on to the third system or the
third method that is the man in the
middle attack so here's the step one
involves Network interception the hacker
positions themselves between the
victim's device and the intended server
intercepting data traffic then comes the
Step 2 Data monitoring the hacker
eavesdrops on the data being exchange
potentially capturing sensitive
information like login credentials or
financial data then comes the step 3
data manipulation in some cases the
hackers May alter the data being
transmitted which can lead to
unauthorized changes or Data Theft so
these were the steps for the man in the
middle attack method now coming to the
fourth method that is SQL injection and
here hackers start with vulnerability
identification so the hacker identifies
a website or application that is
vulnerable to SQL injection due to
improper input validation then comes the
Step 2 injection attempt the input
malicious SQL code often through a web
form or URL parameter to exploit the
vulnerability then comes the step 3
database interaction the attacker SQL
code interacts with the website's
database potentially allowing them to
extract modify or delete data then comes
the step 4 data exfiltration if
successful the hacker can exfiltrate
sensitive data from the compromise
database so this was all about the SQL
injection method and now moving on to
the next method that is farming so in
this method the step one is DNS
manipulation the hacker either Alters
the victim's DNA settings or deploy is
malware that redirects the victim's
traffic to a fraudulent website Step 2
victim redirection when the victim tries
to Access a legitimate website they are
unknowingly redirected to the hacker
controlled fake website then comes the
step 3 that is data collection the
Hacker's fake website collects the
victim's login credentials and other
sensitive information and then comes the
step 4 unauthorized access with the
stolen information the hacker May gain
unauthorized access to the victim's
accounts or use it for malicious
purposes so this is all about this
method that was farming method now
moving on to the next method that is
social engineering so the first step in
this is Target selection the hacker
identifies a Target and gathers
information about them such as their
role workplace and interest pre-text
creation they create a convincing
pretext or scenario such as pretending
to be a trusted colleague I.T technician
or customer service representative then
comes the step 3 deception using the
pretext the hacker manipulates the
victim into revealing sensitive
information like login credentials or
personal data step 4 information
exploitation with the obtain information
the hacker can gain access to accounts
systems or data or use it for fraudulent
activities so this was all about the
social engineering method which hackers
use to hack the person's system now
moving on to the next method that is
phishing attack so in this the first
step is reconnaissance the hacker Begins
by researching the target let's say the
target is a company called ABC
incorporation then comes the step two
creating a fake email the hacker crafts
a convincing email that appears to be
from a trusted Source such as the IT
department of ABC incorporation the
email might have the subject urgent
security update required and then comes
the deception inside the mail there's a
message stating that there has been a
security breach and employees need to
update their login credentials
immediately to protect their accounts
the email contains a link that
supposedly leads to the company's login
page step 4 clicking the link an
unsuspecting employee at ABC
incorporation receives the email and
clicks on the provided link believing it
to be genuine and then comes the step 5
fake login page the link takes the
employee to a web page that looks
exactly like ABC incorporation's
official login page however it's a fake
page created by the hacker then comes
the step 6 and print credentials the
employee thinking they are on the real
login page enters their username and
password then comes the 7th step data
capture the hacker captures the entered
credentials as they are transmitted
through the fake login page then comes
the step 8 unauthorized access armed
with stolen login credentials the hacker
gains access to employees account and
potentially to sensitive company
information so in this example the
hacker used a phishing attack to trick
an employee into divulging their login
credentials this is just one of many
methods hacker used to compromise
security it highlights the importance of
being cautious and verifying the
authenticity of emails and websites
especially when they request sensitive
information to protect against such
attacks individuals and organizations
should regularly educate themselves on
cyber security best practices and use
strong unique passwords for their
accounts these steps outline the general
process involved in each hacking method
it's important to note that ethical
hackers use similar knowledge and
techniques to identify and fix
vulnerabilities helping organizations
improve their security so this was all
about this tutorial and now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers by opting out the boot
camp and the postgraduate program in
cyber security hi I'm Philip I'm 61
years old and last year iobscure was
simply learned postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant
Runner first and if these are the types
of videos you would like to watch then
hit the Subscribe button like and press
on the Bell icon to never miss on future
content until next time stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign